new in theaters this weekend Sicario day
of the Soldado and uncle drew what will
you see this is your weekend ticket
[Music]
Sicario day of the Soldado is new in
theaters this weekend it's the sequel to
the 2015 movie Sicario and brings
Benicio del Toro and Josh Brolin back
together again for more us-mexico border
drug war terrorists transporting action
when the idea came was like kind of cool
and then when I read the cigarette so
hey this is a good movie on its own it's
like twisted turns I was surprised with
myself in this installment the CIA's
Matt Garver must team up with former
undercover hitman cool guy Alejandro
Gillick after they discover the cartels
are smuggling terrorists across the
border
this movie is for you if you enjoyed the
first Sicario you liked gritty action
crime thrillers or you just like
watching Benicio and Josh kick some
major ass and yes Benicio Josh and I are
on first-name basis what's up Ben
Joe uncle drew comes out this weekend
originally a character from new 2012
Pepsi Max campaign NBA star Kyrie Irving
takes uncle drew a mythical elderly
better than you a basketball street
baller to the big screen when Dax played
by lil rel Howery has to rebuild his
team for the annual street ball
tournament the Rutger he calls upon the
skills of uncle Drew and his crew
the uncle drew crew is full of both film
and basketball legends Kyrie Irving
Reggie Miller Nate Robinson Chris Webber
Shaq Lisa Leslie JB Smoove lil rel
Howery Tiffany Haddish Nick Kroll Erica
ash and Mike Epps some of these folks
stop by the Fandango studio for a quick
pickup game of Pictionary
[Music]
time wait can't she's because she like
grunt and do stuff with time enzyme now
yes Wow this movie is for you if you
like feel good sports comedies seeing
check on the big screen tickles you as
much as it does me or you need one more
reason to be jealous of talented athlete
actors I'm not that is your weekend
ticket if you can play Pictionary with
famous athletes or actors who would you
choose and check back next week for a
small film ant-man and the wat now i'm
gonna shrink
[Music]